hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast primary
hyperaldosteronism from A to Z I am soon
falcon bobrucz and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by dia Soren G Soren is a
global leader in the field of bottle
technologies for more than 40 years the
company has been developing producing
and commercializing reagent kits for in
vitro diagnostics worldwide it offers
the broadest range of specialty tests
available in the immuno Diagnostics
market and continually invest in
research and development using its
distinctive expertise in the field of
immuno Diagnostics to deliver a high
level of innovation for more information
please visit dinosaur ENCOM before we
start there a few instructions we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us comments answers also welcome
you can do this by clicking the green
clear night button at the lower left of
the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we'll try to
get to as many as we can today do you
want a better look you can own large the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon at the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't see or
hear this precinct agent properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure to resolve any issues
this is an educational website and arm
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits hmm now let's
get right to today's presenter we're
proud to welcome dr. Jonathan Williams
dr. Williams is an assistant professor
of medicine at Harvard Medical School
and associate physician at Brigham and
Women's Hospital division of
endocrinology diabetes and hypertension
has dedicated his research efforts to
unravel
the intricate relationship between
genetics and environment with respect to
individual susceptibility to cardio
metabolic disease he has over 40
original publications describing the
physiologic and pathologic interplay
arena angiotensin aldosterone system
activity and dietary salt intake in
hypertension insulin resistance heart
disease and obesity dr. Williams is an
active program developer course director
and mentor for the Harvard Medical
School Scholar in clinical research
program I will now turn it over to dr.
Williams for his presentation hi
everybody
as Tracy mentioned my name is Jonathan
Williams and I'm thankful for this
opportunity to speak if you're all about
the topic of primary dosterone ism i'm
actually coming to you today from Salt
Lake City Utah
I've been driving across country taking
my daughter's car out to college for her
so needless to say I've had quite a bit
of time to reflect on this topic for the
last three days as mentioned die Soren
is providing the educational activities
support for this presentation today and
I'm grateful to them and also to lab
leagues for hosting the broadcast so I'd
like to start with a quick case I
understand that there are likely some
primary care providers as well as
laboratory managers on the webinar today
so I'm gonna try to make this applicable
to everybody because this might be a
story of you or somebody you know bob is
a typical patient of mine is a 44 year
old male with a history of hypertension
the last three years
these are initially treated with a blood
pressure medication probably amlodipine
5 milligrams a day which was escalated
to 10 milligrams today over a two-month
period since this failed to control his
blood pressure a second blood pressure
medication
was added lisinopril and it was
increased over the following year
unfortunately despite these efforts
Bob's blood pressure remained
uncontrolled as you can see and I think
this is typical of what we see with
hypertension treatment so this is the
rest of Bob's story as a history of high
cholesterol that was diagnosed in his
late thirties he takes a
cholesterol-lowering medication as well
as a baby aspirin he has what's called
borderline type 2 diabetes or
prediabetes he's obese he says that his
wife's States he snores a lot but claims
he does not hear this suggestive of him
having perhaps sleep apnea he has a
family history of high blood pressure
he's married
doesn't smoke man he's gainfully
employed when we look at Bob's exam you
know that he's obese that he has skin
changes that are consistent with
somebody who might have insulin
resistance just darkening of the skin
folds across the neck here's a large
neck which he suspected it might be the
cause for his snoring
and then we see his laboratory data yes
slightly deep finished renal function
and a normal potassium interestingly his
electrocardiogram shows left ventricular
hypertrophy so would you be worried
about Bob in this case and there'd be a
couple of things that I think would be a
little bit atypical in this situation
the duration of his hypertension is
actually short-lived it's only a few
years at least as what we have recorded
and I think this is often a case in
treating patients with hypertension they
might have arrived at a diagnosis but
have had a pre-existing unknown history
of hypertension for years he has
evidence of end organ damage and that he
appears to already have the image of the
kidneys and has ventricular hypertrophy
so it again suggests that he's had long
duration and out of control
hypertension and then you'll see has
kind of a typical aggregate of
comorbidities which were elevated his
risk he has insulin resistance to
diabetes and yes so what do you do well
you try again you had a you throw a
third blood pressure medication and from
court valadon which is a diuretic and a
month later you see there's no effect
and at this point Bob's asking you you
even know what you're doing as his
treating physician so both patient and
physician are becoming more frustrating
you get laboratory data again because
you had faced him on a diuretic and you
note that his potassium has dropped to
lower than the lower normal 3.1 so now
what do you do well what we say
clinically and training is that when you
here cook beets in the forest don't
think of zebras think of common things
and for the most part common things in
this case would just be run in the mill
essential hypertension but since we know
this is a talk on primary aldosterone is
I'm actually what I'm showing here that
Bob likely has conditioning from primary
hyperaldosteronism all right first we're
going to talk a little bit about
hypertension in general so for the most
part we categorize this into two
sections primary or what's typically
known as essential hypertension
represents about 90% of the hypertensive
population this strongly heritable
they're a host of mechanisms responsible
for it and the treatment is just as
described in this case it's very
nonspecific and it's actually based on
large studies with mean group effects
and I'll describe it that what I mean by
that in a minute
it's basically treatment on an algorithm
approach and as you can see here if one
medication doesn't work then you add a
second one and unfortunately what we
found out is that some of these blood
pressure met
Haitians might even lower blood pressure
but antagonize another system such as
we've recently described that if you saw
restrict some people you can worsen
their insulin resistance even if you
lower their blood pressure and as all
treating physicians know and has
demonstrated in this case compliance
with treatment regiments is very poor if
you look at a population drug effect I
think this is a nice way to kind of view
it you see the frequency of a population
response on the y-axis and then you see
the actual response in this situation it
would be a change in blood pressure or
perhaps even and that health benefit
listed here and you can see the mean
effect would be in the positive for the
population on whole but there can be
negative consequences to portions of the
population this is what's frustrating
and it's basically what I spend my life
doing in research it's trying to figure
out how people develop high blood
pressure and how to better treat
specifically both individuals so I
mentioned primary hypertension the other
form of hypertension morosely described
is secondary hypertension it represents
about 10% of the hypertensive population
we say secondary because we feel that we
understand or can identify the mechanism
responsible therefore the treatment is
actually fairly specific for example
hypertension that's caused by narrowing
of the renal arteries or renal artery
stenosis is obvious defects there are
hormonal mechanisms such as Cushing's
disease pheochromocytoma or aldosterone
is and the topic of today there are
medications such as sudafed which will
raise blood pressure so you can see
these are easy to identify singular
mechanism of hypertension and when and
can be for the most part equally easily
treated so the goal overall in the
hypertension treatment world is to
transform more primary
or unknown mechanistic hypertension into
a secondary form of hypertension that we
can narrowly treat so if you look back
at our graph here where we see the
population effect you could superimpose
on this primary aldosterone ism so we
know if we can identify the population
there is a very specific treatment which
has a very robust robust effect we're
out with very limited negative effects
and this would be the treatment of
spironolactone we'll get into that a
little bit later
so specifically primary aldosterone
isn't is the inappropriate secretion of
aldosterone resulting in dysregulated
volume homeostasis potassium wasting and
hypertension it is a singular mechanism
therefore as we saw in this case it is
typically resistant to off-target
treatments if you use blood pressure
medications that do not specifically
target the problem of aldosterone they
will have very little or limited benefit
in lowering blood pressure unfortunately
it's a very delayed diagnosis if it's
even diagnosed as opposed to primary
aldosterone ism secondary aldosterone is
actually the normal physiologic
stimulation of aldosterone in response
to an hyper profuse State so this might
be if there's massive blood loss how the
body would respond is to reactively
increase the production or and the
secretion of aldosterone in order to
maintain circulating blood Ronny there
are specific clinical conditions in
which we see this also such as
congestive heart failure and cirrhosis
so why what's the importance of primary
health Ostrow nism why are we actually
discussing this at this time well it
actually has to do with the updated
Endocrine Society guidelines that
just released about a month ago in which
they claim in state that this is a real
public health problem that it's being
under-diagnosed and undertreated and
that if you look at the primary
hypertensive population it actually
consists of a sizeable portion why does
this matter well as we just described
it's specifically treatable
you can even cure primary aldosterone
ism yet no one seems to be doing much
about it clinically it's often perceived
as a rare disease and it can be
confusing to even screen for it the
second and perhaps most important reason
is that aldosterone can be a bad player
beyond blood pressure we see that if you
have primary austrian ism you will have
high blood pressure but you will also be
predisposed to developing a multitude of
conditions including aggressive heart
failure increased
left ventricular hypertrophy kidney
disease stroke coronary disease all
these conditions contribute to a
decrease mortality and patients that
have primary aldosterone ism
even if they have the same level of what
control as other patients without the
Austrian ISM so let me just give you a
quick little history of the story of
aldosterone and this is a fun review I
got to do a historical perspective a few
years ago regarding the 50th anniversary
of its discovery actually in 1563 the
Italian Bartolomeo Astacio was the first
to describe the adrenal glands and if he
edged it upon copper plates and if we
advanced forward to 1849
Thomas Edison the father of Addison's
disease described that the destruction
of an adrenal gland leads to death and
the 1930s glucocorticoids were
discovered yet there was known that with
in the adrenal gland
there was another hormone that appeared
to influence the metabolism of sodium
and potassium in 1953 the group here and
I focus on Simpson who is the female so
you'd add the table and to her left is
her future husband Tate and they were
the two that first described electric
Orton and they actually did so by
synthesizing better sorry about that
actually taking over a ton almost a ton
of beef adrenal glands and to identify
21 milligrams of electric Courtin which
is later described as aldosterone
interestingly even back in the 1950s it
was identified that beyond blood
pressure control and regulation of
potassium that the mineralocorticoid
Abbas Rahn appeared to have influence
and fibrosis and inflammation here we
see a pictograph that shows the three
layers of the adrenal cortex the zona
glomerulosa posickey Radha and
reticularis and then below that is the
adrenal medulla the top layer the zona
glomerulosa is where the aldosterone
secretion and production occurs kahn
syndrome is probably the most familiar
representation clinically of hyper
aldosterone it was described in 1955 as
hyperaldosteronism arising from an
adrenal tumor that presented with
hypertension and profound hypokalemia
this is perhaps where the concept of a
rare disease in this regard I came about
as it was defined as only less than 1%
of hypertensives having this form of
hypertension in the ensuing two or three
decades the mechanisms regulation and
aldosterone production and secretion one
identified first the main component
angiotensin ii by arena and sodium
restriction was identified in 90
58 a year later spironolactone the first
mineralocorticoid receptor blocker was
introduced in 1962 has described that
ACTH from the pituitary gland also
stimulated the Austral secretion or
there was a weak player and then by 1972
was described at potassium and sodium
played a role in regulating the response
to angiotensin 2 and rainin and
aldosterone secretion well wait there's
more of course we're talking about
hormones and of course there has to be
feedback Lutz this is intended to be
complicated but what I want to point out
here is that aldosterone main job is to
increase circulating blood volume where
there might be other hormones such as
angiotensin ii and sympathetically
active hormones that increase vascular
tone to raise blood pressure aldosterone
increases blood pressure by increasing
the amount of circulating volume so how
rare isn't it well I think this is the
easiest way to look at conditions such
as primary Bostrom ism here we see on
the y-axis the disease burden the cost
and the degree of irreversibility of the
disease process and you can put any
disease process here you can see that
for the most part diseases such as
primary autism likely occur with a
genetic defect at birth and then they
developed into a clinic or condition
later in life and the degree to which
somebody could detect that detection to
detect the onset the Austrian ISM
depends on whether you're looking and
then whether you have a tools to do so
now unfortunately what we're seeing with
primary Austronesian is that the
detection and realization is not
occurring in so very very late than the
disease
process for the majority of patients
this is important because once things
are let loose and untreated for decades
of time the damage is typically already
done and very difficult to reverse so
what we need to do is push our levels of
detection more to the right side of this
figure the prevalence so this is
actually the number one hormonal cause
of secondary hypertension as opposed to
pheochromocytoma or our Cushing's
disease in fact primary hypertension in
general it appears that about 6% of the
population has the Austral ism or
primary hyperaldosteronism and if you
look at it by stage of hypertension and
this would mean that the severity of
hypertension we see that as the severity
increases you see an increasing
prevalence of primary hyperaldosteronism
and I think it's important to realize
that what this likely means is as we're
catching the disease process far too
late in some of these clinical course if
you look at the most severe forms of
hypertension such as resistant
hypertension which we typically define
as we saw in this clinical case of Bob
at what pressure that's sustained above
140 over 90 millimeters of mercury
despite the use of three
antihypertensives including a diuretic
or the use of four antihypertensives
and if you look specifically within this
population the prevalence of primary
aldosterone ism is 17 to 23 percent this
is a strikingly troublesome figure and
that it means most likely that primary
aldosterone ism has gone undetected for
many many years up to this point finally
an interesting study came out a few
years ago and which case
who had obstructive sleep apnea and new
onset hypertension about a third of them
were found to have primary aldosterone
ism and I mentioned this specifically
for an upcoming reason so there are
several forms of primary aldosterone ism
it's actually represents a group of
disorders the largest by far is what we
termed for now
sporadic primary aldosterone ism and
there are essentially three flavors the
first in the second represents half of
the population each the first is what we
would describe as Kahn syndrome and this
is what dr. Kahn described it's an
adrenal adenoma benign Abbas your own
secreting tumor that occurs in one side
of the adrenal gland here and typically
the contralateral adrenal gland is
somewhat atrophy in response to the high
of Ostrom burden radiographically it's a
very well defined and capsulated tumor I
would say for the most part ranging
between 1 to 2 or 3 centimeters maximum
the second flavor primary aldosterone
ISM is bilateral hypertrophy and as we
see here this represents increased
production of aldosterone and both
glands and this typically has a genetic
underpinning mechanism responsible for
very rarely but important to recognize
is that adrenal carcinoma or primary
adrenal cancer can present with symptoms
and signs consistent with primary
aldosterone in them and on imaging
they're usually very large tumors and
they secrete a variety of hormones and
hormone byproducts and metabolites in
addition to aldosterone rarely but
increasingly important and recognized
are the familia
forms of primary aldosterone ISM
presently we've identified three types
type 1 2 & 3 as I mentioned they're
fairly rare but what we've identified is
that in type 2 it appears that a large
portion of those likely have a genetic
mutation that we also see in adrenal
adenomas x' type 1 as condition which is
important to recognize clinically type 1
also goes by the name glucocorticoid
remedial hyperaldosteronism and it is a
genetic defect in which the promoter for
cortisol is fused in front of the
aldosterone secreting or producing
hormone aldosterone synthase as such
these patients present very young with
very severe forms of hypertension and
the phenotype of early onset strokes so
clinically if you have a patient who's a
young age between late teens and early
twenties who has a family history of
strokes at a young age and presents with
hypertension and your potassium is
important to realize that that screening
for this form of basra nism should be
undertaken so what is the screening
process for primary aldosterone ism well
most people say I know it when I see it
and they typically describe these
telltale signs of patients with primary
austrian ism these patients it is
considered are often young but in
reality this is rarely the case it's
awfully a very loud presentation of
severe hypertension and again this is
very rarely the case and that they
present with hypertension and
hypokalemia or low potassium again in
the majority of patients who have
primary aldosterone ISM they actually do
not present with low potassium levels
as such as I mentioned the endocrine
society updated their screening
guidelines for primary care providers
for primary or boström ism and these are
the six points they made for case
detection first if somebody has a
sustained blood pressure of 150 over a
hundred millimeters of mercury despite
to the use of these medications they
should be screened for primary Ostrom
ism in addition classic findings of
hypertension that hypokalemia should be
screened hypertension with an adrenal
nodule or otherwise known as an adrenal
incident to Roma about two percent of
these end up having primary aldosterone
ism which should be screened as such as
I mentioned in this most recent study
patients who have hypertension and
obstructive sleep apnoea have a very
high likelihood of having primary
aldosterone ism as I mentioned before if
there's a family history of young stroke
victims and hypertension they should be
screened for primary aldosterone ism and
all primary relatives of a patient who's
diagnosed with primary bostrom ism so if
you consider all six of these factors
together this actually could represent a
fairly large subset of the primary care
providers hypertensive population how do
we do it well I think this is the
important part and I think it's very
perhaps one of the most troublesome
parts of the screening process for
primary care providers this is probably
the easiest way I can describe it why do
we use this laboratory study called the
aldosterone lean and ratio well lean in
is actually the main circulating volume
gauge so rhenium is a hormone secreted
by the kidney it's does so in response
to either low circulating brine or row
salt or sodium which results to a
or high-level arena the opposite is true
if there is a high circulating volume
and a high salt content in that Rhine
then a meanin secretion will be
suppressed and the values will be low
the next thing is to consider how
aldosterone works aldosterone as I
mentioned is the main circulating volume
contributor so every ninh job is to
gauge or detect how much volume there is
and aldosterone job is to increase
volume you can see this relationship so
sorry to mention this but I'm an
endocrinologist and endocrinologist live
on feedback loops so we'll go through
this scenario if rainin is elevated
physiologically then aldosterone is
probably elevated to because we see in
this feedback loop that rainin
eventually leads to the production of
angiotensin ii which stimulates
aldosterone release which will increase
circulating blood volume as the volume
expands this world down regulate leanin
release and peel back on aldosterone
secretion
if aldosterone is autonomous which is
what we would see and primary of
darwinism then you can see the feedback
loop will be impaired aldosterone
release will go up autonomously the
circulating blood volume will expand and
rainin will be suppressed and should be
suppressed essentially down to zero as
the volume continues to expand so if we
look at the ratio you typically see an
elevated l dosterone
and it very low renin it's probably
easiest to integrate this into a ratio
such that high ratios high aldosterone
or low rena would provide evidence of an
inappropriate of aztlán secretion so
that being said you have to realize the
power of the denominator
for example let's say we had an
aldosterone level drawn on a patient
which resulted in five nanograms per
deciliter this would actually be
considered a fairly normal level of
aldosterone for most westernized diets
the gerenian activity measured with that
patient might be very very low at 0.1
this would be probably at the lower
limits of detection for that particular
assay and if you convert this into eight
aldo raine and ratio you would have a
very high ratio of 50 and this would be
considered completely abnormal most
ratios for are less than twenty but in
this scenario it doesn't appear to be
because of a very elevated aldosterone
but just a very very suppressed bringing
in influencing the denominator effect so
for this reason most experts advocate
that in addition to an absolute that in
addition to an elevated aldosterone
llenan ratio you should also have an
absolute cutoff for aldosterone in the
upper range the assays so this is the
next most important part of determining
how to interpret aldo v-nand ratios the
most part there are two general
approaches to measuring leanin the
classic approach would be plasma
Orleanian activity reen in is an enzyme
whose job it is to cleave angiotensin ii
one it could sorry
Rinas job is to cleave angiotensinogen
in order to form angiotensin one the
enzymatic assay that's news measures the
speed at which that's done it's a rate
that is generated it's unfortunately
it's a very cumbersome assay and it's
it's expensive to perform it takes a lot
of technical time and it's actually
sensitive to poor sample handling such
that if the samples are frozen at the
wrong time this can influence the
activity and ringing in
get false results it's a fairly
reproducible assay but it's very not as
sensitive at lower levels and
unfortunately as I mentioned before one
of the main influences of Rena activity
is how much salt is in the diet and if
there is a high-salt diet which is
typical of most westernized diet then
renal levels are generally suppressed
and this can be a problem when creating
a ratio as I already mentioned for the
most part and there the assays vary the
normal values for a seated morning
leaning in plasma leaning activity would
be between 1 and 4 nanograms of
angiotensin 1 or cc per hour the next
way to measure enon is actually directly
measure how much rhenium is produced so
it's not an activity assay it's actually
a concentration detection and this can
be done through automated and you know
metric assays the advantage of this
approach over plasma renin activity is
that it can be very very fast it can be
easy it's not as technical it's
unfortunately Green in itself doesn't
affect blood pressure Reena activity or
the enzymatic process is what affects
blood pressure so that could be
considered a limitation by some and its
substrate dependent so how much rhenium
is created depends on the estrogen state
of an individual the normal values are
typically reported between 8 and 35 no
units for leader as the The Endocrine
Society updated guidelines have
indicated the easiest way to kind of
convert directly min concentrations from
plasma marine activity is to multiply by
8 so the suggested screening cutoff
values ratios are listed here below and
these are would be typical of what we'd
see for primary Ostrow nism there's a
table down below which shows
plasma aldosterone concentration on the
left-hand columns and then the different
forms of plasma activity versus the
record meaning concentration across the
top and then there's SI unit designation
and conventional designation listed a
typical strongly suggested elevated
ratio using plasma renin activity would
require a value of lean enough very well
and an elevated plasma dosterone usually
this would be between 20 to 40 as a
ratio for direct leaning concentration
we require a value typically less than 4
no units per liter with an similarly
elevated plasma aldosterone
concentration and aldosterone to direct
llenan ratio of greater than 3.7 the
reason why there are so many different
cut-offs is part of the problem and it's
why the other on strong suspect sorry
the endocrine society wants focus to be
placed on unifying cutoff values the
next most common obstacle in deciding
whether to obtain an Australian ratio is
that all the antihypertensive
medications or a majority of them that
are used can influence rainin and
aldosterone for example diuretic hormone
not it
sorry diuretic blood pressure medication
to actually raise rainin they create a
diaeresis or a dehydration effect which
lowers blood volume and as we mentioned
before this stimulates rainin beta
blockers actually suppress lean and
secretion through sympathetic
stimulation mineral accord accord
receptor drugs such as spironolactone
block the mineralocorticoid receptor
this antagonizes aldosterone secretion
and levels are very very high ACE
inhibitors and AR bees can do all of the
above next
optimizing conditions it's important
that when you're testing for aldosterone
Lane and ratios in a screening process
now you make sure your serum potassium
is as close to normal as possible if
somebody has a low potassium then you
should try to correct that before you
measure the aldosterone inna nation if
they're on a diuretic you should
discontinue it for the reasons I just
mentioned if you're on a
mineralocorticoid receptor agents such
as spironolactone it too should be
discontinued to enhance the aldosterone
mean and ratio effect it should be
encouraged some moderates increase in
salt intake and then importantly these
hormonal assays should be drawn in the
morning after two hours and an upright
or seated position the points to
consider and these for the most part on
minor in light in my view premenopausal
women have higher aldosterone Green and
ratios this has more to do with estrogen
release and in the luteal phase so this
can affect directly Ninh assays rainin
in general decreases with age we're not
sure why this occurs but above the age
of 65 years green ants decrease chronic
kidney disease can be can influence the
aldosterone llenan ratio if marina is
being produced by the kidney yet the
kidney itself is damaged you can quickly
see how that's going to impair the
interpretation of a ratio and should be
referred to a specialist however all
this being said what the endocrine
society update is calling for is to
simplify the screening process in order
to enhance case detection it is clear
that not enough case detection is going
on right now if we're seeing that
upwards of 20% of the hypertensive
population has prevailed ostracism as
such they are calling for establishing
universal assay standards for both
aldosterone
and Rina whether we lean in activity or
meaning concentrations and to facilitate
point of care capacity so this is where
it appears that direct lean and
measurements are going to be favored and
as we move towards on amaizing
automating and facilitating other lean
and ratio measurements direct reading
concentrations may have some very minor
limitations but in the setting of
wanting to increase a screening assays
use those should really not be an issue
as I mentioned before don't be as
concerned with the various
antihypertensive medications that a
patient might be taking or their
possible influence on the aldosterone
llenan ratio it would be better to
obtain the other Australian ratio and
then refer the result to a specialist
for interpretation
now the exceptions would be to make sure
that hydrochlorothiazide chlorothalonil
other diuretic medications be tapered
off beforehand if possible finally a
referral to spit to uh to a specialist
would be required at this point for
confirmation so as with any screening
test it is just meant to enhance the
ability to identify a possible case that
conformation is required and very
quickly how we do that is we establish
that Abbas wound is actually being
autonomously secreted easiest way to do
this is to salt load somebody or volume
road
as I mentioned in the feedback circle if
a high volume or a high-salt diet is
introduced into a patient the normal
response should be to decrease
aldosterone secretion as such if you
load somebody with salt and they still
have an elevated aldosterone that is
confirming that they have autonomous
secretion or primary aldosterone ism
the next step is to subtype as I
mentioned there's two major forms of
aldosterone ism this can be determined
most easily with a cat-scan it allows
you to determine if there's an adrenal
cancer there's a very large tumor on one
side of the adrenal claim that looks
cancerous that would be important to
know it also can help the possible
future surgical interventions adrenal
it's adult
incidentalomas though increase with age
this as people age there's more likely
to be the presence of an adrenal tumor
on CT imaging and this is why the next
step would be to determine
lateralization now what we suggest is
that only try to determine
lateralization or whether a tumor is on
one side or both side if a patient is
going to go for surgery if they are not
either because they do not desire
surgery or they do not seem appropriate
for surgery then medical therapy will be
started if surgery is an option than
what we typically do is proceed to
adrenal vein sampling this must be done
through a specialist that involves the
use of catheters that are threaded into
the left and right adrenal glands to
determine whether one side is over
secreting versus both sides or secreting
medical therapy right now is essentially
two major drugs and then a mineral
Accord equate receptor antagonists the
first spiral lactone as I mentioned was
discovered and they're synthesized in
1953 it's consequently very cheap very
potent it's convenient it's taken once a
day obviously there's a risk of
hyperkalemia as it blocks aldosterone
and more so if a patient has concomitant
renal disease unfortunately this is a
fairly significant dose dependent risk
of breast development in men or
gynecomastia which occurs between 5 and
25 percent of patients on spironolactone
a newer agent
player known was developed about 10 to
15 years ago it's consequently more
specific and that it does not have the
risk of gynecomastia but it is also not
as potent and it cost considerably more
money to prescribe surgery versus
medical therapy there's been a lot of
back and forth about whether a surgical
option is better than just placing
somebody on medical therapy there are no
real good solid studies comparing the
two but in general it's felt that
surgery might be more cost effective
especially in young patients so in those
patients surgery appears to be preferred
unfortunately you need to have a very
experienced laparoscopic surgeon who
knows how to do this type of surgery in
order for its benefit to be gained and
you have to be able to trust the
lateralization data given by the adrenal
vein sampling results at the effective
treatments whether they're surgery or
medical or these blood pressure improves
with surgery up to one year after
surgery there is always and excuse me
there's typically the need for continued
additional blood pressure medication
medical therapy spironolactone at very
low doses lowers blood pressure by about
a quarter in most patients this equates
to losing about a half a blood pressure
medication in that population however
the effects beyond blood pressure are
what's important there is improved
cardiovascular risk improved progression
to chronic kidney disease and strokes
and mortality outcomes are include with
blockade or removal of aldosterone
so in conclusion primary Ostrom is a
prevalent and actually virulent like
uniquely treatable form of hypertension
case detection should be instituted if
sustained blood pressure hypertension
is is seen despite the use of an
aggressive blood pressure
program regardless of whether a patient
has hypokalemia the best way to test is
that morning aldosterone and rhenium
lean and testing gun without withdraw of
hypertensive medications
aside from thiazide elevated aldosterone
beam and ratios should prompt referral
to a specialist for the conformation
testing and management
so in conclusion we'll go back to our
figure here of case detection the push
from endocrinologists and the endocrine
Society is that we hopefully will
identify in an earlier time course
individuals who have primary aldosterone
ism such that more specific and directed
therapy can be invoked to provide more
effective results thanks for your
attention and be happy to take any
questions at this time
with an excellent presentation dr.
Williams thank you for bringing the
information to us it was terrific before
we get started with all of your
questions
here's a quick reminder about how to
reach us today so questions can be sent
via the green Q&A button at the lower
left of their presentation window just
type in your questions hit Send and
we'll try to get to as many questions as
we can today so our first question for
dr. Williams is is there a preference of
measurement of plasma reading activity
or directory ninh so the there's not
there doesn't appear to be a preference
at this time I would say that plasma
renin activity historically has been
used more than rina concentrations as
pointed out and the endocrine guidelines
most recently released direct reading
concentrations probably will have
favorite status down the road simply
because it's a much easier assay to
conduct it is not as expensive there is
increasing amounts of data that supports
that direct reading concentrations in
plasma rina activities correlate so the
hope is that any assay that is going to
improve or enhance the ability or
facilitate the providers ability to
order and screen for primary oestrus
dosterone ISM will be the more favored
assay there's certainly and in academic
circles I would say there's back and
forth regarding the the advantages of
one assay over the other but I would
fall back to the endocrine society's
recommendation that we do what we can to
enhance and improve facilitate the
screening process